Narrator: TONIGHT...
YOU GUYS
ARE THE AMERICAN DREAM,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHY WE DO THIS SHOW.
...A SPECIAL EPISODE FEATURING
PRODUCTS ALL MADE IN AMERICA.
HOW COOL IS THAT?
THAT'S COOL.
YEE-HAW!
Narrator: IN THE TANK,
ENTREPRENEURS SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
DAMN, KEVIN!
ALL RIGHT, DOWN, BOY,
DOWN, BOY, DOWN, BOY.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
HALLELUJAH.
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I LIKE IT.
I'M IN.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I WILL GIVE YOU EXACTLY
WHAT YOU CAME IN ASKING FOR.
DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
WAIT.
OKAY.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
SHUT UP, SCOOBY-DOO.
YOU KNOW WHAT, BARB,
YOU WANT TO GO IN WITH ME?
I'M GONNA GO IT ALONE,
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'LL DO IT AT 15%.
WHOA.
OH!
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A UNIQUE TOOL
TO MAKE THE MOST
OF A TRENDY FRUIT.
GREETINGS, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS DAVE GOODMAN.
I'M FROM NEW YORK CITY, AND
MY COMPANY IS CALLED COCO JACK.
I'M HERE ASKING FOR $125,000 IN
EXCHANGE FOR 10% OF MY COMPANY.
SHARKS,
THESE ARE YOUNG THAI COCONUTS.
THEY'RE ENJOYED BY HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WORLDWIDE.
THERE'S JUST ONE LITTLE PROBLEM.
IT'S HOW YOU USUALLY
GET INTO THEM.
OH, MY GOD.
DO YOU EVER MISS?
WE GET E-MAILS ALL THE TIME
FROM PEOPLE WHO DO.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THERE'S GOT TO BE
AN EASIER WAY.
AND NOW THERE IS.
INTRODUCING THE COCO JACK.
COCO JACK OPENS
YOUNG THAI COCONUTS SAFELY
IN JUST A FEW SECONDS, NO MATTER
YOUR SIZE OR STRENGTH.
WE'VE HAD ABOUT 1,000 PEOPLE
DOING THIS,
FROM 4-YEAR-OLD KIDS TO LITTLE
OLD LADIES, EVERYONE IN BETWEEN.
JUST LIKE THAT, AND THERE --
YOU'RE IN.
JUST TAKES A FEW SECONDS.
Herjavec: CAN I TRY IT, DAVE?
OF COURSE, YEAH.
DO YOU HAVE TO
FLIP THE HAMMER?
YES, THAT'S IN THE INSTRUCTIONS.
[ LAUGHS ]
THERE YOU GO. WHO ELSE
WANTS TO COME UP AND TRY IT?
WHOA, ROBERT.
SURE.
Herjavec:
GIVE ME A COCONUT, DAVE.
Goodman:
RIGHT. HERE YOU GO.
SO, THE COCO JACK GOES
ON TOP OF THE COCONUT LIKE THIS.
YOU WANT TO HIT IT
A FEW TIMES.
DAMN, KEVIN!
COME ON, KEVIN!
ALL RIGHT, DOWN, BOY,
DOWN, BOY, DOWN, BOY.
LITTLE OVERKILL. THAT'S
WHAT WE CALL COCO THERAPY.
ALL RIGHT, LET ME TRY.
AND YOU'RE IN, YEAH.
THAT'S PLENTY.
GIVE IT ONE MORE FOR GOOD LUCK
IN THE FRONT.
HAVE YOU TRIED
THESE COCONUTS BEFORE?
NO.
YOU HAVEN'T?
NO. CAN I TRY?
HERE'S A STRAW.
OF COURSE.
OH, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
ENJOY.
Greiner:
SO, I HAVE A QUESTION.
WHERE DO YOU GET
THE COCONUTS LIKE THAT?
THEY COME LIKE THIS FROM
THAILAND. IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THAI COCONUTS ARE
THE SWEETEST COCONUTS ON EARTH.
YOU CAN GET THEM
AT ANY ASIAN MARKET,
MOST MEXICAN/LATINO MARKETS,
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS,
AND ALMOST ANY WHOLE FOODS
OR HEALTH FOOD STORE.
THE BEST PART OF THE COCONUT
IS ACTUALLY THE MEAT.
AND WE HAVE A STAINLESS-STEEL
SCOOP TOOL, AS WELL,
THAT'LL GET ALL THE MEAT OUT.
IS THAT YOUR TOOL?
YES, SIR.
THIS IS A BIG, BIG SELLING POINT
FOR THE TOOL, AS WELL.
ALL THE MEAT'S GONNA COME OUT
JUST LIKE THAT IN ONE PIECE.
Greiner: OH, WOW.
THAT, TO ME, IS MORE IMPRESSIVE
THAN THE FIRST PRODUCT.
WHAT DO YOU GET
IN THE COCO JACK PACKAGE?
THIS IS IN THE COCO PACK, AND
THAT COMES IN THE BURLAP SACK
THAT SHOULD BE OVER THERE
IN FRONT OF YOU.
DAVE, I'VE HEARD THAT
DRINKING EXCESSIVE COCONUT WATER
ACTUALLY CAUSES
A LAXATIVE EFFECT.
ANY TRUTH TO THAT?
[ CHUCKLES ]
I'M NOT A DOCTOR.
BUT, YEAH, I THINK
THERE CAN BE A CLEANSING EFFECT.
O'Leary:
GIVE ANOTHER ONE TO BARBARA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HERE YOU GO.
Herjavec: AND IT'S VERY, VERY
HEALTHY FOR YOU, RIGHT, DAVE?
IT'S EXTREMELY HEALTHY.
IT'S VERY HYDRATING.
IT'S FULL OF ELECTROLYTES.
IT'S VERY GOOD. SWEET.
TASTES LIKE CORN.
Corcoran: HOW DOES A GUY
LIKE YOU COME UP WITH AN IDEA
OF BEING
IN THE COCONUT BUSINESS,
AND WHERE DID YOU GET THAT
OUTFIT IN A TOWN LIKE NEW YORK?
YOU DON'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME.
I KNOW. I'M A COMPLICATED GUY.
AND I'M ACTUALLY
FROM NEW YORK CITY.
I SOLD MY APARTMENT IN NEW YORK
2 1/2 YEARS AGO
TO LIVE FULL-TIME ON THE ROAD.
I BOUGHT FOUR R.V.s.
AND I'M PREP-SCHOOL RAISED.
AT 14 YEARS OLD, I HAD
A CLASSICAL MUSIC CONVERSION.
WENT TO JUILLIARD
AS A PERCUSSIONIST, A COMPOSER.
WOW.
I WAS A CONDUCTOR.
I WENT OUT TO CALIFORNIA.
I STARTED STUDYING ECONOMICS.
I STARTED STUDYING
MYTHOLOGY, POLITICS.
BECAME A PRIVATE PILOT
IN COLORADO.
THIS HAS SOMETHING TO DO
WITH COCONUTS?
I'M GETTING THERE.
A FRIEND OF MINE TURNED ME ON
TO A RAW VEGAN DIET,
AND COCONUTS WERE A BIG PART
OF THE REGIME.
AND I OPENED THEM ALL THE TIME
WITH MY CLEAVER, AND I SAID,
"THERE'S GOT TO BE
A BETTER WAY TO DO THIS."
THIS IS
A VERY INTERESTING STORY,
BUT I MISSED THE PART
WHERE I MAKE THE MONEY.
Greiner: OKAY, SO WHO IS SELLING
THE COCO JACK RIGHT NOW?
ME. PRIMARILY THROUGH
OUR WEBSITE.
Herjavec:
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
ABOUT 325,000
IN 9 MONTHS.
HOW MUCH
DO YOU SELL THEM FOR?
AVERAGE ABOUT $60.
WHAT'S YOUR COST
TO MAKE IT?
RIGHT NOW,
THEY'RE MADE IN THE U.S.A.
FOR THESE TOOLS, ABOUT $26.
WHEN THIS WAS
A GLIMMER IN YOUR EYE,
FROM THE FIRST MOMENT,
HOW MANY YEARS
DID IT TAKE YOU TO GO FROM
GLIMMER TO AN ACTUAL PRODUCT?
I HAD THE IDEA
ABOUT 12 YEARS AGO.
12 YEARS TO GET YOUR PRODUCT
OFF THE GROUND?
WELL, I WASN'T TRYING
FOR 12 YEARS.
YOU WEREN'T PASSIONATE ENOUGH
TO, LIKE, DIVE IN?
I WAS OCCUPIED
WITH OTHER THINGS.
I WAS PASSIONATE
ABOUT OTHER THINGS AT THE TIME.
ONCE I GOT INTO IT, I THOUGHT,
"OKAY, I'M MAKING THIS
FOR 20,000, 50,000,
MAYBE A MILLION RAW FOODISTS
IN VENICE BEACH
AND ORANGE COUNTY."
WHEN I STARTED DOING
CUSTOMER DEVELOPMENT,
PEOPLE SAID, "NO, DAVE,
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
"EVERY THAI RESTAURANT,
EVERY VIETNAMESE RESTAURANT,
ALL THE PAN-ASIAN RESTAURANTS,
THEY ALL SELL COCONUTS."
I'M CURIOUS
HOW ORGANIZED YOU ARE.
HMM. GREAT QUESTION.
I PREFER CREATIVE THINKING.
I ALSO BELIEVE IN OUTSOURCING
STUFF I'M NOT GOOD AT.
I HAVE THREE PEOPLE
WHO ARE BEAN COUNTERS,
NO. OKAY. SO --
AND THEY'RE VERY AGGRESSIVE
ABOUT THAT.
AND I'M NOT GONNA
SPEND MY ENERGY --
OKAY. TIME OUT.
WANT TO GET A WORD IN HERE.
EVERY TIME I INVESTED
IN AN ENTREPRENEUR
WHO WASN'T ORGANIZED
OR HAD A RIGHT-HAND PERSON THAT
TOTALLY ORGANIZED THE BUSINESS,
GUESS WHAT?
THEY NEVER DELIVER.
MY --
AND THEY SPENT MY MONEY
SO QUICKLY AND NOT SO WISELY.
OKAY.
THAT'S A FAIR CRITICISM.
SO, FOR SIMPLY THE REASON
OF LACK OF ORGANIZATION,
WHICH I BELIEVE
I'M RIGHT ON,
I HAVE TO BE OUT.
WELL, I HAVE
SOME GOOD NEWS FOR YOU.
OKAY.
AND I HAVE SOME BAD NEWS
FOR YOU.
THE GOOD NEWS IS
I LOVE IT.
I THINK THAT YOU HAVE
A MARKET FOR THIS.
IT'S GOT MERIT,
IT'S USEFUL,
AND YOU WILL SELL THEM
TO SOME PEOPLE.
OH, YEAH.
BUT TO THE BAD NEWS,
I'M OUT...
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
A BIG-ENOUGH MARKET
FOR ME TO INVEST IN IT.
DAVE, I REALLY LIKE
THE IDEA.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
I MEAN, I LOVE STUFF THAT IS
OBTUSE, THAT IS VERY UNIQUE,
THAT IS A LITTLE BIT OUT THERE,
KIND OF LIKE YOU.
YOU THINK?
BUT I DON'T SEE
THE NEXT STEP.
I JUST DON'T SEE IT.
I'M OUT.
O'Leary: OKAY, DAVE.
I'VE GOT A LITTLE STORY FOR YOU.
THIS VARIETY OF COCONUT
IS PROMINENT IN CAMBODIA,
WHERE I GREW UP
WHEN I WAS YOUNG.
MY HOUSEKEEPERS BACK THEN
USED TO TAKE ME TO THE MARKET
EVERY MORNING,
AND I WOULD WATCH IN FASCINATION
WITH THE MASTERY THEY HAD
TO CARVE IT INTO THIS SHAPE
AND THEN KNOCK THE TOP OFF,
PUT A WOODEN STRAW IN IT,
AND THAT WAS MY BREAKFAST.
I LOVE THAT.
SO, BECAUSE I'VE HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH THE COCONUT
AND I FEEL THE CONNECTION,
I'LL GIVE YOU $125,000
FOR 50%.
FIVE-ZERO PERCENT?
YEAH.
$125,000 FOR 50%?
CORRECT, ROBERT.
GET THE MACHETE, DAVE!
YOU'RE NOT A BUSINESS YET.
YOU'RE A PRODUCT.
THERE'S A LOT
THAT CAN GO WRONG
TURNING IT
INTO A BUSINESS.
I THINK I'VE MADE YOU
A FAIR OFFER.
I'VE GIVEN YOU $125,000
TO BECOME A PARTNER.
HAS ANYBODY ELSE
STEPPED UP?
SO, DAVE, OKAY.
SO, I LIKE THE IDEA.
WHEN PEOPLE SOLVE PROBLEMS
THAT NOBODY KNEW
NEEDED TO BE SOLVED...
YEAH.
...INDUSTRIES ARE BORN.
INDUSTRIES?
SHUT UP, SCOOBY-DOO.
IF -- IF I SAY, "LOOK, WE CAN GO
AFTER BARS AND RESTAURANTS,
BUT WE CAN'T
GO AFTER SOMETHING ELSE,"
CAN YOU FOCUS
ON ONE THING AT A TIME?
ABSOLUTELY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DEBT
IN THE COMPANY NOW?
ABOUT $13,000.
OKAY.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU $125,000
STRUCTURED AS CONVERTIBLE DEBT
WITH A 7% INTEREST RATE.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS
I'M NOT GONNA ASK YOU
TO PAY ME BACK INITIALLY, RIGHT?
IT'S JUST GONNA
STAY ON YOUR BOOKS AS DEBT.
RIGHT.
IF BUSINESS GOES GREAT,
WE'LL CONVERT THAT TO EQUITY,
AND I'LL JUST BE
AN EQUITY SHAREHOLDER.
WHAT I WANT THAT TO CONVERT TO
IS 25% OF THE COMPANY.
O'Leary:
DAVE, AND I JUST WANT YOU
TO UNDERSTAND ONE THING
WITH CERTAINTY.
IF THINGS DON'T GO WELL AND YOU
TAKE ON THAT CONVERTIBLE DEBT,
YOUR PATENT AND THE OWNERSHIP
OF YOUR PRODUCT
WILL REVERT
TO THAT CONVERTIBLE DEBT OWNER.
MINE HAS NO DEBT COVENANTS.
WE'RE TOTALLY ALIGNED,
100% ALIGNED AS PARTNERS.
I DO WANT TO SEE
IF YOU'D BE INTERESTED
IN GOING DOWN TO 20%
FOR THE EQUITY CONVERSION.
NO.
LOOK, YOU TAKE EQUITY,
OR YOU TAKE DEBT.
ONE OTHER THING JUST TO ADD IN.
DAVE, YOU GOT TO
CLOSE THE DEAL!
YOU HAVE TO DECIDE.
ARE YOU TAKING DEBT OR EQUITY?
THAT'S YOUR DECISION, DAVE.
I THINK YOU'RE THE LUCKIEST MAN
IN THE WORLD.
I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU HAVE A SINGLE OFFER.
SO, WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO, DAVE?
YEAH, I'LL TAKE IT.
I'LL TAKE IT. I'M SOLD.
WE GOT A DEAL?
WE GOT A DEAL.
LET'S DO IT.
DEAL.
THANK YOU, MARK.
APPRECIATE IT, BRO.
THANKS, BRO.
WE'LL DO THIS.
COCONUTS FOREVER.
RIGHT ON.
LATER, GUYS.
THANKS. YOU WERE AWESOME.
GOOD LUCK.
ALL RIGHT!
THANKS.
IT'S BEEN A LONG
AND WINDING JOURNEY.
I'VE DONE ALL KINDS OF THINGS
IN MY LIFE.
I'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN ALL OF THEM.
AND THIS IS BRINGING ME
INTO THE PEER GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE MASTER SUCCESSFUL PEOPLE
LIKE MARK.
I'M REALLY EXCITED FOR THAT.
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK IS A PRODUCT
DESIGNED TO MAKE AN ACTIVITY
OF THE PAST MORE SAFE.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS GEORGE CONWAY,
AND I'M FROM CHATTANOOGA,
TENNESSEE.
MY COMPANY'S CALLED BedRyder.
I'M SEEKING $200,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 15%
OF MY COMPANY.
SHARKS, RIDING IN THE BACK
OF A PICKUP TRUCK --
THERE IS NOTHING BETTER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE PROBLEM IS,
IT'S JUST NOT SAFE UNTIL NOW.
I love that accent.
NOW, KEEP IN MIND,
I'M 53 YEARS OLD,
AND THIS IS NOT THAT BAD.
WOW.
JUST SLIDE THE SYSTEM
IN THE VERY BACK.
POPS IN.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
IN THERE ALREADY
THAT YOU'RE
ATTACHING IT TO?
THERE'S THREE BOLTS
THAT ARE UNDERNEATH THE TRUCK.
YOU HAVE TO DRILL SOME HOLES,
AND BOLTS ARE PUT IN.
SO, YOU HAVE TO DRILL --
IN ORDER TO INSTALL THESE,
YOU HAVE TO DRILL THESE HOLES?
YES, SIR.
THE BedRyder SYSTEM ADDS THE
CONVENIENT SEATING OF AN S.U.V.
TO THE ROLE
OF A PICKUP TRUCK,
CREATING WHAT WE IN THE SOUTH
LIKE TO CALL A TRUCK-U.V.
HOW COOL IS THAT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT'S COOL.
YEE-HAW!
THAT'S COOL, ISN'T IT?
A TRUCK-U.V.
THINK ABOUT IT.
YOU TAKE AN S.U.V. RIGHT HERE,
AND THIS IS THE TRUCK.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN, THEY'RE
COMING TO AN INTERSECTION.
THEY CRASH.
THIS IS WHAT YOU GOT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THIS IS IT!
HAVE YOU TESTED?
HAVE YOU DONE CRASH TESTING?
I -- YOU WANT --
HONESTLY, YES.
I HAVE DONE MY OWN
BY ACCIDENT. I WAS --
BY ACCIDENT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE WERE AT -- WE WENT TO
A NASCAR RACE DOWN IN ATLANTA.
WHO'S "WE," GEORGE?
MY BEST FRIEND, KERRY.
MM-HMM.
THE ACTUAL INVENTOR.
AND HIS TWO SONS.
Herjavec: WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
YOU'RE NOT THE INVENTOR?
I AM HIS BEST FRIEND.
I AM THE SALES MANAGER.
Greiner: WAIT A MINUTE. I JUST
WANT TO HEAR WHAT HAPPENED --
ON THE ACCIDENT.
THE CAR GOT DESTROYED
PRETTY GOOD.
EVERYBODY WAS FINE
IN THE TRUCK.
GEORGE, I SEE THE SKIES
RAINING DOWN WITH LITIGATION.
THE FLAW IS,
EVERYBODY THINKS IT'S ILLEGAL
TO RIDE IN THE BACK OF A PICKUP.
I THOUGHT IT WAS.
QUITE FRANKLY, IT IS.
HOWEVER --
[ LAUGHTER ]
HOWEVER, IT IS ILLEGAL TO RIDE
IN THE BACK OF A PICKUP TRUCK
UNRESTRAINED.
WE'VE HAD IT
INDEPENDENTLY TESTED,
AND IT MEETS AND EXCEEDS
ALL FEDERAL GUIDELINES.
YOU ARE COMPLETELY LEGAL.
EVERY STATE?
EVERY STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
Cuban: WELL, LET'S ASK
THE OBVIOUS QUESTIONS.
SO, HOW MUCH HAVE YOU SOLD?
HOW MANY STATES
HAVE YOU SOLD THEM IN?
HOW ARE YOU SELLING THEM?
I'VE SOLD 800 UNITS SO FAR
ON THE INTERNET.
Corcoran: OVER WHAT PERIOD
OF TIME WERE THOSE SALES?
FOUR YEARS.
Herjavec:
WOW, THAT'S LOW.
WHERE IS THE INVENTOR?
WHY ISN'T HE HERE?
THE INVENTOR, KERRY HIDE,
HAS BEEN MY BEST FRIEND
SINCE WE WERE 7 YEARS OLD.
KERRY HANDLES
ALL OF THE OPERATIONS.
HE GETS THE CHAIRS ASSEMBLED,
GETS THEM BROUGHT
TO OUR PLACE IN ATLANTA.
THEN I'M THE PERSON
IN CHARGE OF ALL THE SALES.
OKAY, SO KERRY
STARTED THE COMPANY
AND OWNS WHAT PERCENTAGE?
HE OWNS 85% OF THE COMPANY.
Corcoran: OHH.
BUT DO YOU HAVE
THE OTHER 15%?
DID YOU GET THE 15%?
YES, I HAVE THE 15%.
YES.
THE TRUTH IS THIS BUSINESS
REALLY CAN'T SUPPORT BOTH OF YOU
OR EITHER ONE OF YOU.
NOW, THERE'S A HUGE INDUSTRY
SELLING AFTERMARKET PRODUCTS
TO GUYS WHO HAVE PICKUP TRUCKS
ALL OVER AMERICA.
WHY DON'T YOU HAVE THESE
AVAILABLE THERE?
SINCE I'VE COME ABOARD
SIX MONTHS AGO,
I HAVE ACTUALLY WORKED
WITH AN ONLINE COMPANY
THAT THAT'S THEIR BIGGEST THING
IS TRUCK ACCESSORIES.
IN FACT, WE JUST SIGNED A DEAL
WITH THEM.
SO, GEORGE, IS THAT HOW
YOU'RE GONNA GROW THE BUSINESS?
IS THAT HOW
YOU'RE GONNA SCALE?
I HAVE FIVE DIFFERENT OTHER WAYS
THAT I AM GOING TO GROW
THIS COMPANY.
THE FIRST
IS I HAVE 800 PEOPLE
WHO INVESTED IN MY COMPANY
AND BOUGHT MY UNITS FROM ME.
SO, BASICALLY,
I'M CALLING ALL THESE CUSTOMERS,
AND I'M OFFERING THEM INCENTIVE
TO BECOME MY SALES REPS.
THEY'RE GONNA GET $100
FOR EVERY SALE THAT THEY MAKE.
I LOVE
THE WAY YOU SELL, GEORGE.
YOU ARE A GOOD SALESPERSON.
Corcoran: VERY GOOD.
Herjavec:
WHERE ARE YOU MAKING THESE?
EVERYTHING IS MADE IN AMERICA.
THE FRAME IS WHAT
WE MANUFACTURE.
WE GET THE SEATS AND THE COVERS
FROM ATLANTA.
WE GET THE HARNESSES SENT IN
FROM MICHIGAN.
GEORGE, WHAT'S IT COST YOU
TO MAKE ONE?
$300.
I SELL THEM FOR $699 A SET.
GEORGE, IT'S A GREAT IDEA.
BUT HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE, MY FRIEND.
IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE MANUFACTURING
THIS FOR, LIKE, 100 BUCKS
TO PUT IT INTO WHOLESALE
AT $300
IN ORDER TO SELL IT AT RETAIL
AT $500 TO $600.
EXACTLY.
SO, HOW ARE YOU GONNA DO THAT?
HOW AM I GONNA DO THAT?
I HAVE THE ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION, BY THE WAY.
HALLELUJAH!
HALLELUJAH.
I WILL BUY 1,000 UNITS.
IF I GET $200,000,
I WILL SPEND IT AND BUY 1,000
UNITS, AND I WILL RE-NEGOTIATE,
AND I WILL BRING MY PRICE
DOWN TO $200 A UNIT.
YOU KNOW, I WORRY ABOUT CRASHES,
AND I WORRY ABOUT ROLL-OVERS.
FOR ME,
I CAN'T GET PAST THAT.
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
I JUST WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT MY DOOR IS ALWAYS OPEN,
SO IF YOU DECIDE YOU WANT
TO COME ON BACK IN, I'M HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GEORGE, I WANT TO HIRE YOU.
I LOVE YOU, GEORGE.
FORGET THE BUSINESS.
I JUST WANT TO HIRE YOU.
O'Leary: JUST LOVE
LISTENING TO YOU. YOU'RE GREAT,
BUT I WANT YOU,
WHEN YOU LEAVE THE TANK,
TO TAKE THAT TRUCK
AND DRIVE IT OFF A CLIFF.
MR. WONDERFUL,
I REALLY LIKE YOU.
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE.
I LIKE YOU, TOO.
BUT DOOR'S ONLY OPEN
FOR SO LONG, SIR.
I'M TRYING TO SAVE YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
O'Leary:
OKAY, LOOK, GEORGE.
I'D LIKE YOU
TO GET RID OF THIS THING
SO YOU CAN GO SELL SOMETHING
WHERE YOU MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
I REALLY WOULD.
HOWEVER, ON THIS
PARTICULAR IDEA, I'M OUT.
OKAY. THAT'S FINE.
GUYS, LET ME STEP IN.
I LIKE THE PRODUCT.
LOVE YOU.
LOOK, YOU KNOW
BETTER THAN ANYBODY
IT'S A HUGELY
CASH-INTENSIVE BUSINESS.
ABSOLUTELY.
CASH-INTENSIVE
DOESN'T BOTHER ME
WHEN YOU'RE TURNING INVENTORY
A LOT AND IT'S VERY PREDICTABLE.
RIGHT.
BUT YOU HAVE NO IDEA
WHEN THE NEXT ORDER IS COMING
OR AT WHAT FLOW
THEY'RE GONNA COME.
THAT MEANS YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO ALWAYS HAVE
TOO MUCH MONEY
SUNK INTO INVENTORY,
WHICH MAKES IT
FAR MORE DIFFICULT
FOR ME TO GET A RETURN
ON MY INVESTMENT,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
UNDERSTAND COMPLETELY.
Herjavec: GEORGE, I THINK
YOU DID A GOOD JOB TODAY.
GREAT.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
I REALLY LIKE THE PRODUCT.
I JUST DON'T SEE IT
REPLACING S.U.V.s.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
Corcoran: FOR ME...
I THINK THIS IS
A PHENOMENAL IDEA.
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT
SAYS FUN, FUN, FUN,
AND EVERYTHING ABOUT IT,
I ASSOCIATE WITH HAPPY MEMORIES.
MY DAD USED TO LET
3 OF HIS 10 KIDS
HANG OFF THE BACK OF HIS STATION
WAGON EVERYWHERE WE WENT.
THAT'S WHY
THERE'S ONLY THREE LEFT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LET ME MENTION
ONE OTHER THING.
YOU'RE A 15% PARTNER.
WE'RE NOT EVEN TALKING
TO THE MAJORITY SHAREHOLDER,
THE GUY
WHO RUNS THE BUSINESS.
WE HAVE -- WE'VE DISCUSSED THIS
IN GREAT DETAIL.
I HAVE FULL AUTHORITY TO MAKE
WHATEVER DECISION IS MADE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
MILLION-DOLLAR QUESTION?
WHO'S KERRY?
I DON'T KNOW
WHO I'M BUYING INTO, SO I'M OUT.
OKAY.
LOOK, YOU GOT TO TELL KERRY
HE REALLY SCREWED UP.
MM.
WELL --
NO, YOU SCREWED UP.
I SCREWED UP?
YOU KNOW WHY?
'CAUSE YOU'RE THE SALESMAN,
AND YOU SHOULD'VE KNOWN BETTER.
YOU SHOULD'VE THOUGHT
OF THAT OBJECTION.
SO OBVIOUS.
YES.
O'Leary: I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT LESSON.
AND, GEORGE,
MY OFFER STANDS.
YOU, ME,
CAN OF GAS, A MATCH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I CAN'T DO THAT, BOSS.
THANK Y'ALL.
Herjavec: TAKE CARE.
I WISH I'D HAD KERRY
OUT THERE WITH ME.
I THINK IF KERRY CAME OUT THERE,
WE WOULD'VE NAILED IT.
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A BUSINESS
POISED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE LUCRATIVE
SORORITY MARKET.
♪ DO, DO, DO-WOP-WOP ♪
♪ DO, DO, DO-WOP ♪
♪ WE HOPE
THE SHARKS PICK FRILL ♪
[ LAUGHS ]
I LIKE IT. I'M IN.
HI. I'M SHARON.
AND I'M KATE.
AND WE ARE FRILL.
WE ARE ASKING FOR $100,000
FOR A 20% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
FRILL CLOTHING
DESIGNS AND PRODUCES
CUSTOM RECRUITMENT CLOTHING
FOR SORORITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND IN CANADA.
RECRUITMENT IS WHERE
POTENTIAL NEW MEMBERS
RUSH VARIOUS SORORITIES
ACROSS THEIR COLLEGE CAMPUS.
IT'S BEEN A LONGSTANDING
TRADITION
FOR SORORITIES TO DRESS
IN UNISON DURING RUSH WEEK.
AS A SORORITY GIRL MYSELF,
I WAS TIRED OF BUYING
EXPENSIVE AND UNFLATTERING
CLOTHING YEAR AFTER YEAR.
IN ADDITION,
MULTIPLE PROBLEMS
CAN ARISE
FROM THESE BULK ORDERS.
SORORITIES
GENERALLY DON'T KNOW
IF THE VENDOR HAS ENOUGH
IN STOCK FOR THE ENTIRE CHAPTER.
THE GIRLS TYPICALLY DON'T
GET TO TRY ON THE PIECES
BEFORE ORDERING,
THUS CAUSING FIT ISSUES,
AND WORST OF ALL, THEY DON'T
KNOW IF ANOTHER SORORITY
AT THEIR SCHOOL IS GONNA BE
WEARING THE EXACT SAME OUTFITS.
OH, NO.
THE HORROR!
FRILL SOLVES
ALL THESE PROBLEMS.
WE COME TO EACH CHAPTER
INDIVIDUALLY, HOST FITTINGS,
AND PRODUCE PIECES
FOR EACH SORORITY.
SO, WHAT DO YOU SAY, SHARKS?
WILL YOU RUSH FRILL?
O'Leary:
I JUST WANT TO GET THIS RIGHT.
YOU GO TO EVERY SORORITY
IN THE NATION, THEORETICALLY.
THANK YOU.
AND SAY, "LISTEN,
WE'RE GONNA DESIGN
"A UNIQUE OUTFIT FOR JUST YOU
THAT SHOWS YOUR ALLEGIANCE."
IS THAT TRUE?
IS IT UNIQUE TO EVERY SORORITY?
Steadman: IT IS UNIQUE
TO THAT CHAPTER AT THAT SCHOOL,
BUT WE DO HAVE
THE SAME PIECES
AT DIFFERENT CHAPTERS
ACROSS THE U.S.
HOW MANY ARE THERE
IN THE UNITED STATES?
THERE ARE 3,127 SORORITY ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND IN CANADA.
WHAT WOULD YOU CHARGE
FOR THAT PARTICULAR DRESS
FOR A SORORITY MEMBER?
THIS DRESS WOULD GO FOR
BETWEEN $100 AND $120.
CUSTOM-MADE?
WELL, EACH OF OUR PIECES
IS CUSTOM-MADE,
SO IT WOULD COST
ABOUT $120,
BUT IT DEPENDS ON THE NUMBER
OF GIRLS IN EACH SORORITY.
IS THE IDEA TO GET EVERY GIRL
TO BUY THE SAME DRESS
SO WHEN THEY GO TO A FUNCTION,
THEY ALL LOOK THE SAME?
START FROM SCRATCH.
CAN YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN
HOW RUSH WORKS?
YES. THESE SORORITIES
HAVE DIFFERENT THEME DAYS.
AS THE DAYS GO ON,
THE OUTFITS GET MORE FORMAL.
SO, THE FIRST DAY,
THEY'RE WEARING A T-SHIRT,
BUT BY THE END OF THE WEEK,
THEY'RE WEARING A FORMAL DRESS
LIKE THIS.
IS THE POINT
THAT YOU FEEL LIKE A TEAM?
YOU ALL LOOK ALIKE.
YES.
YOU TAKE PICTURES.
MM-HMM.
EXACTLY.
SO, WHAT DOES
A SKIRT LIKE THIS --
WHAT DO YOU MAKE IT FOR,
AND THEN WHAT DOES IT COST?
THAT SKIRT
COSTS $24 TO PRODUCE,
AND IT SELLS FOR
BETWEEN $60 AND $70.
AND DO YOU MAKE THEM
IN AMERICA?
ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
FROM LAUNCH, WE'VE DONE
JUST OVER $400,000 IN SALES.
WOW.
GOOD FOR YOU.
BUT TWO OF THOSE YEARS, WE WERE
FULL-TIME COLLEGE STUDENTS.
OUR FIRST YEAR IN BUSINESS
AS JUNIORS IN COLLEGE,
WE DID $37,000 IN SALES
AND STARTED THE COMPANY
WITH ONLY $500.
WOW.
LAST YEAR,
AS SENIORS IN COLLEGE,
WE DID $149,000 IN SALES.
WHAT IS THE LEAD TIME
TO ORDER?
WE TAKE ORDERS
FROM FEBRUARY TO MAY.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF YOUR SALES
COME IN THAT SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME?
ABOUT 70%.
WHOA.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE
A BRIDAL DIVISION.
WE STARTED OUR BRIDAL DIVISION
IN JANUARY OF 2013
WHEN OUR PICTURE WENT VIRAL
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
WITHIN A MONTH,
WE LITERALLY HAD HUNDREDS
OF BRIDAL PARTIES
CONTACTING US,
BEGGING TO MAKE THESE OUTFITS
FOR THEIR BRIDESMAIDS.
SO, A TYPICAL GIRL
IN A RUSH WEEK
WOULD BUY SEVEN DRESSES
OR SEVEN OUTFITS FROM YOU?
THEY SPEND
ABOUT $500 FOR RUSH.
YOU'RE KILLING IT, YEAH.
THESE GIRLS WILL BY FROM US
FOUR YEARS IN A ROW,
AND THEN
ONCE THEY GRADUATE,
THEY'LL COME BACK TO US
FOR THEIR BRIDESMAID OUTFITS.
TELL ME
ABOUT YOUR COMPETITION.
WE HAVE ONE
DIRECT COMPETITOR,
AND THEN WE HAVE
BIG-BOX COMPETITORS
JUST LIKE J.CREW
AND LILLY PULITZER.
Cuban:
AND YOU DESIGN THEM CUSTOM.
SO YOU GET TO SAY,
"THIS IS YOURS,
AND YOU DON'T KNOW
WHO YOU'RE GONNA RUN INTO
THAT HAS THE SAME THING
FROM J.CREW."
EXACTLY.
WHAT DO YOU NEED
THE MONEY FOR?
TO RAMP UP PRODUCTION
SO THAT WE CAN
INCREASE OUR MARGINS
BY PAYING LESS PER PIECE.
Cuban: GUYS, LET ME
GET THINGS ROLLING HERE.
OF EVERYBODY HERE,
I'M PROBABLY THE ONLY ONE
WHO HAS EXPERIENCE
SELLING TO SORORITIES.
WHEN I WAS IN SCHOOL,
I USED TO GO SORORITY HOUSE
TO SORORITY HOUSE
AND OFFER MY SERVICES
TO TEACH DANCE...
[ LAUGHTER ]
...LINE DANCES
AND DIFFERENT DANCES.
Greiner: SERIOUSLY?
COME ON.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
I USED TO MAKE $25 AN HOUR.
I MADE A KILLING.
IT WAS THE BEST THING EVER.
WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS VERY IMPRESSIVE.
AND YOU'RE SMART. YOU'RE DOING
ALL THE RIGHT THINGS.
BUT DESPITE
MY MANY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE,
I DON'T THINK
I'M THE BEST FIT FOR YOU.
AND SO I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU AN OFFER.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU
YOUR $100,000,
BUT FOR A THIRD
OF THE BUSINESS.
OKAY.
SO, VALUING YOUR BUSINESS,
YOU CAME IN FOR $500,000.
SHE'S OFFERING YOU
A $300,000 VALUATION.
DOES ANYONE ELSE
HAVE AN OFFER?
LOOK, I LIKE IT.
I LIKE IT.
I'M GONNA MAKE THE SAME OFFER.
Corcoran: YOU CAN'T EVEN
ENTERTAIN THAT FOR A MOMENT,
BECAUSE HE'D
SCARE EVERYBODY AWAY.
Herjavec: NO, HE'S GREAT.
NO ONE WANTS HIM
IN YOUR BUSINESS.
KATE --
I MADE YOU A VALID OFFER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
MY BIGGEST FAN BASE
IS OUT THERE IN THE SORORITIES.
KATE?
THEY LOVE MR. WONDERFUL.
Herjavec: KATE?
YES?
OKAY.
Greiner:
YOU'RE THEIR FAVORITE.
I LOVE IT.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT
BIG FISH, LITTLE POND.
I LOVE THIS MARKET,
BECAUSE IF YOU CAN CAPTURE IT,
YOU'RE GONNA DOMINATE
A NICHE MARKET.
I LOVE IT.
MORE THAN THAT...
LOVE YOU GUYS.
I MEAN, TO BE THIS YOUNG
AND THIS LEVEL-HEADED
AND HAVE SUCH
A GREAT STRATEGY --
IT'S IMPRESSIVE.
THANK YOU.
I CAN HELP YOU
GROW THE BUSINESS.
I WILL GIVE YOU EXACTLY
WHAT YOU CAME IN ASKING FOR.
$100,000 FOR 20%.
DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
WAIT.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
YES OR NO?
WHILE WE'RE SELLING --
Narrator: KATE AND SHARON
HAVE THREE OFFERS
FOR THEIR CUSTOM
SORORITY RECRUITMENT
CLOTHING BUSINESS, FRILL.
BARBARA AND KEVIN HAVE BOTH
OFFERED $100,000 FOR 33%,
BUT ROBERT
HAS COMPLICATED MATTERS
BY OFFERING THEM
EXACTLY WHAT THEY ASKED FOR.
I WILL GIVE YOU
$100,000 FOR 20%.
DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
WAIT.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
YES OR NO?
WHILE WE'RE SELLING --
WAIT A SECOND.
DO YOU WANT TO HEAR MORE
OR NOT?
HE'S NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
I'M NOT GONNA NEGOTIATE
WITH THE OTHER GUYS.
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING.
YOU CAME IN
LOOKING FOR $100,000 FOR 20%.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO NEGOTIATE.
Greiner:
I'D MAKE YOU AN OFFER,
BUT I THINK ROBERT
WOULD HAVE A HEART ATTACK.
HE WANTS IT SO BADLY.
WHAT IS THERE
TO THINK ABOUT?
$100,000 FOR 20%.
DO YOU WANT TO HEAR MORE
OR NOT?
IT'S WHAT
YOU WERE ASKING FOR.
Greiner: YOU GUYS?
Corcoran: KEVIN.
BARBARA MADE YOU AN OFFER --
$100,000 FOR 33%.
WE'RE GONNA MODIFY OUR OFFER.
WE'RE MODIFYING OUR OFFER.
WE'RE GOING IN TOGETHER.
KEVIN -- OH.
YOU'LL GET TWO SHARKS
FOR THE PRICE OF ONE.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE TWO SHARKS,
THAT CHANGES THE WHOLE GAME.
Corcoran: LET ME MENTION
ONE OTHER THING.
THERE'S A BUSINESS
I INVESTED IN LAST SEASON
CALLED GRACE AND LACE
WHICH, BY FAR,
HAS BEEN
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS
SELLING ANYTHING
IN THE DESIGN SPACE.
THEY WENT FROM LESS THAN
$1 MILLION IN SALES
TO $7 MILLION IN SALES.
I HELPED SOURCE THEIR SOCKS,
GOT THEM A CHEAPER PRICE.
I INTRODUCED THEM TO THE BIGGEST
SUPPLIER IN NEW YORK CITY.
I'VE ADVISED THEM ON WHAT
TO GO FOR, WHAT NOT TO GO FOR.
THEY'RE BRILLIANT PEOPLE.
THEY'RE BRILLIANT,
JUST LIKE YOU GUYS ARE.
BUT LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
I WORK THAT BUSINESS,
AND THEY LEAN ON ME.
YOU AIN'T GONNA GET THAT
FROM ROBERT.
I LIKE TWO SHARKS
ON THIS ONE.
WELL, I THINK --
YOU NEED TO ACCELERATE, AND
YOU NEED TO GET EVERY CAMPUS.
THE OPPORTUNITY'S NOW.
WE'RE BOTH GONNA WORK VERY HARD
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
I'M GONNA BE FOCUSED.
AND I'LL KEEP HIM ON A LEASH.
SO, IT'S BARBARA AND KEVIN.
THERE'S A LOT OF TALK
OVER THERE.
FOR $100,000 AT 33%.
AND THEN YOU HAVE ROBERT --
$100,000 AT 20%, WHICH IS JUST
WHAT YOU CAME IN ASKING FOR.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
[ WHISPERING INDISTINCTLY ]
WOULD YOU GUYS BE WILLING
TO TAKE IT DOWN TO 30%?
YEAH.
YES.
THEN WE WANT YOU
TO JOIN FRILL.
YO!
O'Leary:
I'M GOING BACK TO SCHOOL!
WELCOME TO THE SORORITY.
THANK YOU.
NICELY DONE.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
I THINK I'M IN SHOCK.
AND WE STARTED
WITH NOTHING.
THIS IS THE AMERICAN DREAM
RIGHT HERE.
Narrator:
IN SEASON FIVE,
DAYMOND JOHN OFFERED
TO MENTOR MOZIAH BRIDGES,
AN 11-YEAR-OLD FASHION DESIGNER
WITH A HANDMADE BOW TIE
BUSINESS.
IN 1989, I WAS OFFERED $10,000
FOR 40% OF MY COMPANY.
I'M GLAD I DIDN'T
TAKE THAT MONEY.
I STRONGLY SUGGEST
YOU DON'T TAKE ON INVESTORS
AT THIS TIME.
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
Moziah: I DIDN'T GET A DEAL
ON "SHARK TANK,"
BUT I GOT SOMETHING MUCH BETTER.
TRAMICA, MO.
HOW YOU DOING?
BRING IT IN FOR A FAMILY HUG.
A MENTORSHIP WITH
MY FASHION IDOL, DAYMOND JOHN.
THIS FACTORY'S GONNA HELP GET
MO'S BOWS ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
WE ONLY HAD $55,000 IN SALES.
NOW, SEVEN MONTHS
AFTER "SHARK TANK,"
WE'VE REACHED
ALMOST $200,000 IN SALES.
WE NEED A MANUFACTURER
MORE THAN EVER,
AND WE KNEW
DAYMOND COULD HELP US OUT.
THIS IS ROBERT
FROM ROBERT STEWART.
HEY, MO.
HOW ARE YOU?
I FOUND MO
THE PERFECT MANUFACTURER --
ROBERT STEWART,
A MANUFACTURER
THAT'S BEEN HAND-MAKING TIES
FOR 100 YEARS.
THIS IS GOOD, OLD
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING.
GOOD, OLD MADE IN THE U.S.A.
THAT'S RIGHT.
Moziah: BEING MADE BY HAND
AND BEING MADE IN AMERICA
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO ME.
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
THAT YOU STAND BEHIND YOUR TIE,
AND IT HELPS KEEP JOBS
IN THE ECONOMY.
THIS IS WHAT YOU DO AT HOME.
NOW YOU CAN DO IT IN A FACTORY.
John:
WE HAD TO FIND A MANUFACTURER
THAT COULD MEET THE DEMAND
AND STAY TRUE TO MO'S MISSION.
IT'S A PERFECT MATCH.
THIS HAS BEEN AMAZING. THANK YOU
FOR SHOWING US THE FACTORY.
PLEASURE.
ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING THINGS
THAT HAPPENED TO MO'S BOWS
IS THE C.E.O. OF NEIMAN MARCUS
PERSONALLY REACHED OUT TO US.
SHE WANTED TO DO A TEST
OF MO'S BOWS IN NEIMAN MARCUS.
[ CHUCKLES ]
NEIMAN MARCUS
IS THE GOLD STANDARD
OF LUXURY RETAIL STORES.
DESIGNERS SPEND ALL THEIR LIVES
ATTEMPTING TO GET HERE,
AND MO HAS DONE IT
AT 13 YEARS OLD.
YOU DO WELL,
YOU COULD BE
IN EVERY NEIMAN MARCUS
IN THE WORLD.
Moziah: SEEING MY BOW TIES
IN NEIMAN MARCUS
MAKES ME FEEL LIKE
I ARRIVED.
SINCE COMING ON
"SHARK TANK,"
EVERYTHING HAS CHANGED
IN MY LIFE.
NOW IT'S MY TURN.
LET'S DO SOME SHOPPING.
John: I MADE SOME AMAZING DEALS
ON "SHARK TANK,"
BUT THIS MENTORSHIP
IS SPECIAL TO ME.
I WAS MENTORED BY GREAT PEOPLE.
I'M TRYING TO PAY IT FORWARD,
AND HE'S MAKING ME PROUD
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
MY NAME'S
MICHELLE BARSOSKY,
AND THIS IS MY HUSBAND,
JASON BARSOSKY.
AND WE LIVE IN AMHERST,
NEW HAMPSHIRE,
WITH OUR 5-YEAR-OLD TWINS
ABBY AND EMMA.
AFTER WE WERE MARRIED,
JASON AND I DECIDED
THAT WE WERE GONNA
START A FAMILY.
WE HAD TROUBLE
CONCEIVING.
WE ENDED UP GOING TO
FERTILITY TREATMENTS.
AND OUR TWINS WERE BORN, AND
THEY'RE THE LIGHT OF OUR LIVES.
I THINK MY LIGHT-BULB MOMENT
WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT,
TRYING TO FEED TWO BABIES
AT ONE TIME.
I WAS HAVING A REAL HARD TIME
GETTING THE BABIES POSITIONED,
AND I JUST COULDN'T FIND
ANYTHING THAT WAS WORKING.
AND SO I THINK
IT'S JUST OUT OF NECESSITY
THAT YOU END UP
COMING UP WITH SOMETHING.
WHEN THE GIRLS WERE YOUNG,
JASON AND I GOT A PHONE CALL
THAT THEY WERE HAVING LAYOFFS
AT OUR COMPANY.
WE LOST EVERYTHING.
IT WAS SCARY.
IT WAS VERY SCARY,
AND WE NEEDED MONEY.
AND THAT'S WHEN WE DECIDED
TO TAKE A LEAP OF FAITH.
DO YOU LIKE THE LIGHT PINK,
OR DO YOU LIKE THE DARKER PINK?
THERE'S SO MANY
MOMS OF TWINS.
IT'S REALLY A GROWING POPULATION
OF BABIES.
Jason:
WE'VE REACHED A POINT
WHERE WE NEED SOME GUIDANCE
AND SOME FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO REALLY GET THIS THING
TO TAKE OFF.
WE KNOW WE HAVE A PERFECT
PRODUCT FOR A GROWING MARKET,
AND WE CAN BRING
A LITTLE COMFORT
TO FAMILIES
OF TWINS EVERYWHERE.
HI, MY NAME'S MICHELLE.
AND I'M HER HUSBAND,
JASON.
OUR COMPANY
IS THE TWIN Z PILLOW.
WE ARE SEEKING $75,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR A 10% SHARE IN OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, DID YOU KNOW
THAT IT CAN TAKE
A MOM OF MULTIPLES OVER 12 HOURS
A DAY TO FEED HER BABIES?
ONE INFANT FEEDS
30 TO 45 MINUTES AT TIME
12 TIMES A DAY,
AND THAT'S DOUBLE FOR TWINS.
WHEN I HAD MY TWINS,
I SEARCHED AND SEARCHED
FOR SOMETHING
TO HELP ME FEED THE BABIES,
BUT I COULDN'T FIND ANYTHING
THAT WAS COMFORTABLE
OR FIT MY BODY.
SO, I TOOK MY MOM'S
30-YEAR-OLD SEWING MACHINE
AND CAME UP
WITH THE FIRST TWIN Z PILLOW.
THIS IS HOW
THE TWIN Z PILLOW WORKS.
SHARKS, A TWIN Z PILLOW
IS THE FIRST PILLOW
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY
FOR MOMS OF MULTIPLES.
AS YOU CAN SEE HERE,
MOM CAN BOTTLE-FEED
OR BREAST-FEED TWO BABIES
AT ONE TIME, CUTTING THOSE
FEEDING TIMES IN HALF,
LEAVING MOM AN EXTRA SIX HOURS
IN HER DAY.
AND THE TWIN Z PILLOW HAS A VERY
UNIQUE BACK SUPPORT SYSTEM
UNLIKE ANY OTHER PILLOW
ON THE MARKET.
NO MORE HUNCHING OVER
WITH NECK AND BACK PAIN FOR MOM.
SO, SHARKS,
WE'LL HELP YOU
DOUBLE YOUR MONEY
IF YOU JOIN OUR...
DOUBLE TROUBLE TWIN-TASTIC
TWIN Z PILLOW TEAM.
MICHELLE, WHY WOULDN'T
TWO PILLOWS WORK HERE?
WELL, BETWEEN PROPPING UP
WITH YOUR BACK,
AND PROPPING UP ON THE SIDES,
AND THE BABIES ROLL OFF,
THERE'S A LOT OF LOGISTICS
THAT GO INTO HAVING TWO INFANTS.
AND ALSO,
WHAT'S GREAT ABOUT THIS PILLOW
IS PREGNANT MOMS, BEFORE
THEY'VE EVEN HAD THE BABIES,
THEY SIT IN IT LIKE A CHAIR,
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
BACK PAIN WHEN YOU'RE PREGNANT.
O'Leary: MY GREAT CONCERN
ABOUT THIS CONCEPT
IS WE HAVE TO FIND
PARENTS WITH TWINS,
WHICH IS SOME SUBSET
OF A SUBSET
OF THE POPULATION
THAT HAPPEN TO BE HAVING BABIES.
IN THE UNITED STATES,
THERE'S 135,000 TWINS
BORN EVERY YEAR.
ALL RIGHT,
WHAT HAVE YOU SOLD, MICHELLE?
THIS YEAR, WE'RE ON TRACK
TO DO $510,000.
$510,000.
REALLY?
YEP.
YEAR-TO-DATE,
WE'RE AT $300,000.
AND HOW LONG
HAVE YOU BEEN IN BUSINESS?
2 1/2 YEARS.
Herjavec: WHAT DOES IT SELL FOR?
$99.99.
WHOA.
Greiner: HOW MUCH DOES IT
COST YOU TO MAKE ONE?
$29.
Herjavec: WHAT DO YOU THINK
YOU'LL SELL NEXT YEAR?
$1.2 MILLION
TO $1.5 MILLION.
WOW, YOU'RE VERY CONFIDENT.
WHAT DO YOU BASE THAT ON?
BASED ON OUR SALES,
WE DOUBLE EVERY NINE MONTHS.
ALL RIGHT, SO
HOW'D YOU COME UP WITH THIS?
MY HUSBAND AND I BOTH GOT
LAID OFF AT OUR CORPORATE JOBS,
AND --
WHAT DID YOU USED TO DO?
WE WERE BOTH
IN PHARMACEUTICAL SALES.
YEAH.
SO, WHEN WE LOST OUR JOBS,
WE HAD NO CARS. WE HAD
NO PHONES. WE HAD NOTHING.
SO I WENT TO WASHING CARS
FOR A FRIEND OF MINE
WHILE I WAS
LOOKING FOR WORK.
AND ALL HER FRIENDS
KEPT COMING OVER AND SAYING,
"YOU SHOULD REALLY
PATENT THAT PILLOW."
AND SHE GOES,
"THIS IS A GREAT TIME.
I'M GONNA STAY HOME
WITH THE GIRLS."
GOOD FOR YOU, BECAUSE THERE'S
GONNA BE PEOPLE WATCHING AT HOME
THAT ARE IN SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCES,
THINKING, "IF I ONLY
KNEW SOMEBODY, IF I ONLY
HAD CAPITAL AVAILABLE."
YOU DIDN'T KNOW ANYBODY.
YOU PUT IT ALL ON THE LINE,
AND YOU WENT FOR IT.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S THE AMERICAN DREAM,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHY WE DO THIS SHOW.
DID YOU SAY
WHERE YOU'RE MANUFACTURING?
Michelle:
WE MANUFACTURE IN THE U.S.
THE PILLOWS
ARE MADE IN GEORGIA.
THE COVERS ARE MADE
IN MASSACHUSETTS RIGHT NOW.
SO, HOW MANY PROTOTYPES
DID YOU GO THROUGH?
AND TELL ME
ABOUT THE PROCESS.
I TOOK MY MOM'S
SEWING MACHINE.
DID YOUR MOM
HELP YOU SEW THEM?
NO, UNFORTUNATELY,
MY MOM,
SHE HAD PASSED AWAY
BY THE TIME --
I'M SORRY.
RIGHT BEFORE
THE GIRLS WERE BORN,
WE HAD GONE THROUGH A LOT
OF IVF TREATMENTS, AND WE HAD --
WE HAD A LOT OF LOSSES.
AND I JUST SAID,
"I CAN'T DO THIS ANYMORE."
IT WAS LITERALLY
THE LOWEST TIME IN MY LIFE.
COME TO FIND OUT THAT MY MOM,
AFTER HAVING M.S. FOR 35 YEARS,
WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH PANCREATIC CANCER.
I'M SORRY.
SO, WE SAID, YOU KNOW,
IF WE HAVE ONE CHANCE
OF HER MEETING HER GRANDCHILD,
WE'D TRY IT ONE MORE TIME.
AND, SO, WE DID, AND --
WE GOT PREGNANT
WITH ABBY AND EMMA.
YEAH.
NOW THEY'RE 5.
SHE MADE IT TO SEE THEM.
SHE LIVED A GREAT,
WONDERFUL FOUR MONTHS,
AND I KEPT
HER SEWING MACHINE.
YOU GUYS ARE AMAZING
ENTREPRENEURS.
THANK YOU.
YOU GUYS ARE
THE AMERICAN DREAM
AND DESERVE
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE EARNED.
THANK YOU.
BUT IT'S JUST NOT A FIT
FOR WHAT I DO,
AND SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME, MARK.
THANK YOU FOR THE KIND WORDS.
OH, NO.
YOU EARNED IT.
THANK YOU.
JASON, I'M CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA DO WITH THE MONEY.
SO, BIG-BOX RETAILER CALLED US
ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO.
buybuy BABY.
THEY SAID THEY'D LIKE
TO START IT OUT ONLINE,
BUT PROBABLY
BRING IT INTO THE STORE.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES,
WHEN YOU HAVE
A VERY NICHE-ORIENTED PRODUCT
LIKE THIS...
YEAH.
...GOING INTO GENERAL RETAIL
ISN'T ALWAYS --
RIGHT. RIGHT.
...I MEAN, I HATE
TO SAY NO TO ORDERS...
NO, WE AGREE.
...BUT I GOT TO TELL YOU,
IF I'M MAKING GOOD MONEY, $26,
SELLING IT FOR $99 --
THAT WAS OUR THOUGHT.
...AND YOUR CUSTOMERS
ARE FINDING YOU,
I DON'T KNOW IF GOING TO RETAIL
IS THE RIGHT APPROACH.
I DON'T KNOW
IF I AGREE WITH THAT.
I COULD EASILY SEE THIS
IN A MASS MARKET LIKE WALMART.
NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
EASILY. WHY NOT?
I AGREE WITH BARB. I THINK YOU
SHOULD BE EVERYWHERE YOU CAN BE.
NO, I THINK
YOU'RE WRONG.
I THINK THAT'S A MISTAKE.
I DON'T SEE
WHY YOU WOULD HOLD IT BACK.
YOU CAN SELL IT
ON YOUR WEBSITE,
BUT YOU CAN ALSO
BE IN RETAILERS.
YOU'RE GONNA DOUBLE OR TRIPLE
YOUR MONEY.
O'Leary: ALL RIGHT, GUYS, LOOK.
I'LL GIVE YOU AN OFFER.
BUT 10% DOES NOT GET ME EXCITED
ABOUT EQUITY AT ALL.
SO, THE WAY I LOOK AT IT
IS I'LL GIVE YOU $75,000.
I WANT A $10 ROYALTY
UNTIL I'M PAID BACK $225,000.
SO, THREE TIMES ON MY MONEY,
THEN MY ROYALTY GOES AWAY.
AND TO INITIATE
THIS RELATIONSHIP,
I WANT 2.5% EQUITY.
THAT'S CALLED
A PACT WITH THE DEVIL.
Jason:
$10 OFF OF EACH SALE?
YES.
WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER YOU GET YOUR $225,000?
IT'S GONE. YOU DON'T PAY ME
ANYTHING ANYMORE.
THEN HE EATS YOUR CHILDREN.
Herjavec:
WELL, ACTUALLY, I'M GONNA
DO SOMETHING I'VE NEVER DONE.
I'M GONNA MAKE
A ROYALTY OFFER.
AFTER SIX SEASONS, I'VE LEARNED
HOW THEY WORK FROM KEVIN.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $75,000.
I WANT THE SAME $10 PER UNIT,
BUT I ONLY WANT TO GET PAID BACK
TWICE THE AMOUNT
AS OPPOSED TO
KEVIN'S THREE TIMES.
SO, AT $150,000,
AND THE SAME 2.5% FOR EQUITY.
THAT'S MY OFFER.
IT'S SIMILAR TO KEVIN'S,
BUT OBVIOUSLY MUCH BETTER.
RIGHT.
NO OFFER FROM THE LADIES,
AND MARK'S OUT.
WELL, I THINK
YOU SHOULD PUT THEIR DEALS
IN YOUR MENTAL SHREDDER.
[ IMITATES SHREDDER ]
GONE.
I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT ONE.
SO, HERE'S MY OFFER.
Narrator:
ONE SHARK IS OUT.
MICHELLE AND JASON
HAVE TWO OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR BREAST-FEEDING PILLOW
FOR TWINS, TWIN Z.
BUT LORI ALSO SEEMS INTERESTED.
I WOULD LIKE TO OFFER YOU
$150,000.
I'M GOING TO, INTERESTINGLY,
ALSO WANT A ROYALTY.
WHOA!
$5 ROYALTY PER.
KEVIN'S GETTING
CONTAGIOUS HERE.
YES, SIR.
YES, HE'S RUBBING OFF.
Greiner:
ONCE I'M PAID BACK THE $150,000,
THEN I'LL TAKE
A 5% EQUITY STAKE,
'CAUSE I WANT TO HAVE
SKIN IN THE GAME.
I HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH buybuy BABY,
AND I THINK
THAT YOU SHOULD BE EVERYWHERE.
WHY NOT?
Corcoran:
I RESPECT LORI'S OFFER,
BUT I'D LIKE TO COMPETE
WITH THE OFFER.
Michelle: OKAY.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $75,000,
BUT I MUST ASK
FOR 20% OF THE BUSINESS.
BUT I'D LIKE
TO EXPLAIN TO YOU WHY.
WHEN I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN A 10% OWNERSHIP
WITH ANY OF THE BUSINESSES,
AS MUCH AS I LOVE
MY ENTREPRENEURS,
AFTER A WHILE, THAT 10%
LOOKS SMALLER AND SMALLER
AS I'M WORKING MY BUNS OFF
TO PUSH THAT BUSINESS AHEAD.
SO, NOW I'D LIKE
TO PLAN FOR THE LONG HAUL.
TO LORI'S POINT
ABOUT GETTING IN RETAIL,
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE.
WHAT'S WRONG
WITH THE GUYS' PRESENTATION
ABOUT JUST KEEPING IT ONLINE
IS ALL THE JOY
OF BUILDING A BUSINESS
IS TO DREAM
AND SEE HOW FAR YOU COULD GO.
Herjavec:
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO ELIMINATE
MOST OF THE UNIVERSE?
BARBARA, YOU'RE VERY CONFUSED,
BECAUSE
YOU KEEP FORGETTING RETAIL'S AT
HALF THE MARGIN,
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE CAPITAL
TIED UP IN RETAIL.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S KEY IN RETAIL?
NO. YOU KNOW --
YOU'RE TYING UP CAPITAL
IN RETAIL.
HEY.
I CAN PROVIDE THAT FUNDING.
BUT YOU TOOK A SHOT
AT MY DEAL,
AND YOU HAVE TO PAY THE PRICE
FOR THAT.
YOUR DEAL IS ROBBERY.
SO, LOOK,
AS A MATTER OF FACT --
HE'S SUCH A SHORT MAN.
THEY ALWAYS ARE PUSHY.
...HOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO HAVE TWO SHARKS
INSTEAD OF
ONE NOISY ONE?
I'M GONNA PROPOSE
TO ROBERT RIGHT NOW
THAT HE COMES INTO MY DEAL
UNDER THE SAME TERMS
THAT I ORIGINALLY PROPOSED SO
I'M NOT COMPETING WITH MYSELF.
NOW YOU HAVE TWO SHARKS.
KEVIN, I LIKE THE OFFER,
OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S RICHER THAN MINE,
SO WHY WOULDN'T I LIKE IT?
BUT CALL A SPADE A SPADE.
IT'S NOT AS GOOD
AS LORI'S OFFER.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
UP THE MONEY.
LORI'S A SINGLE SHARKETTE.
BESIDES,
HE TOTALLY DOESN'T SEE
WE'RE TWO SHARKS.
THAT A MAN WITH MONEY IS NO
MATCH FOR A WOMAN ON A MISSION.
WHAT I'M SUGGESTING,
KEVIN,
IS WE GO WITH TERMS
OF YOUR OFFER.
YES.
WE SIMPLY BUMP THE MONEY
TO $75,000 EACH.
DONE.
KEVIN AND I ARE GONNA OFFER
$150,000 IN TOTAL,
$10 OFF EVERY PILLOW.
ONCE WE'RE PAID BACK
TIMES THREE,
IT CONVERTS
TO 2.5% EQUITY.
MICHELLE AND JASON,
CAN I SAY WHAT IS WRONG
WITH ALL OF THE DEALS
ON THE TABLE OTHER THAN MINE?
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH SKIN
IN THE GAME.
AND YOU'RE THE PRINCIPALS
OF THE BUSINESS.
WHATEVER YOU DON'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH, FINE.
I ROLL OVER.
BUT WHAT I CAN GIVE TO YOU,
WHICH IS TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT,
IS A LONG-TERM PARTNERSHIP.
WHICH IS WHAT
I WOULD GIVE YOU, TOO.
EXCUSE ME, I'M NOT FINISHED.
Cuban: WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT BEING
CAPITAL CONSTRAINED AT ALL,
ROYALTY DEALS
MAKE NO SENSE WHATSOEVER.
THEY COST YOU TOO MUCH.
SO, FROM YOUR POSITION --
I WANT TO EXPLAIN SOMETHING.
Herjavec: HE'S ABSOLUTELY WRONG.
I PUT MY HEART AND SOUL
INTO ALL MY ENTREPRENEURS.
FROM YOUR POSITION, THOUGH,
GUYS, NEGOTIATE.
O'Leary: YOU CAN TALK
TO ALL MY ENTREPRENEURS, TOO.
YADA, YADA, YADA.
NO, MY HEART AND SOUL IS IN IT,
AND I'M A PART OF THE FAMILY.
WE'RE ONE BIG FAMILY.
I'M CHANGING MY DEAL BECAUSE
KEVIN'S JUST SO AGGRAVATING.
O'Leary:
LET'S HEAR IT.
YOU KNOW, BARB,
YOU WANT TO GO IN WITH ME?
SO, $75,000, 20%.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA DO?
Herjavec: EACH?
I COULD BE WRONG HERE.
I'M GONNA GO IT ALONE.
Greiner:
OKAY. MY OFFER IS THIS.
$75,000, AND I'LL ASK
FOR A 20% EQUITY STAKE.
WAIT, THAT'S
THE SAME THING I OFFERED.
SO I HAVE MATCHED
BARBARA'S OFFER.
O'Leary:
ALL RIGHT, LET'S JUST RECAP.
BOTH BARBARA AND LORI
HAVE SUGGESTED $75,000 FOR 20%
AND A JOURNEY INTO THE DARK
RETAIL HELL THAT WE SPOKE OF.
THE OTHER, FROM ROBERT AND I --
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU $150,000
AGAINST A $10 ROYALTY
UNTIL WE GET BACK EACH $225,000,
WHICH IS THREE TIMES
ON OUR MONEY,
AND WE'RE ONLY TAKING
FROM THE BUSINESS 2.5% EQUITY,
WHICH I THINK IS VERY FAIR,
ACTUALLY.
YOU'VE HEARD THE MERITS
FROM BOTH SIDES.
NOW MAKE YOUR DECISION.
OKAY. SO...
WOULD YOU GUYS BE WILLING
TO GO $75,000 FOR 15%?
YOU'RE SAYING
YOU WANT US TOGETHER?
I THINK WE BOTH --
WE SEE THE VALUE IN,
OBVIOUSLY, BOTH OF YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
SOMETHING ABOUT 7.5%
DOESN'T GET ME GOING
IN THE MORNING.
YEAH, IT'S HARD FOR US.
WE WORK HARD.
WE PUT OUR HEART AND SOULS --
WOULD EITHER OF YOU CONSIDER
DOING THAT ALONE?
WE'VE REALLY WORKED HARD.
WE HAVE NO DEBT ON THE BOOKS.
WHAT IF YOU GOT
BOTH OF US AT 20%?
[ WHISPERS INDISTINCTLY ]
WE DON'T WANT THAT?
YEAH, I'LL DO IT AT 15%.
YEAH?
ALL RIGHT.
I'LL DO IT AT 15%.
WHOA.
OH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
O'Leary:
WHOA. MICHELLE, YOU SNAKE.
WOW.
VERY CLEVER, JASON.
WHAT IF ROBERT AND I
KNOCK DOWN --
INSTEAD OF MAKING
THREE TIMES ON OUR MONEY,
WE ONLY MADE TWO TIMES,
AND WE ONLY TOOK 2.5% EQUITY?
AND YOU GET TWO SHARKS.
AND WE'RE GONNA DROP OUR ROYALTY
FROM $10 TO $7.50.
SO, A TOTAL
OF $300,000 BACK?
Herjavec: YES.
RIGHT.
GUYS, YOU GOT TO
MAKE A DECISION.
[ WHISPERS INDISTINCTLY ]
YEAH.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, LORI.
YOU HAVE A DEAL.
LORI, YOU HAVE A DEAL.
YAY!
[ SIGHS ]
I REALLY WANTED IT.
YAY!
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANKS.
CONGRATS, GUYS.
GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
Michelle:
WE WENT WITH LORI BECAUSE
LORI HAS SO MUCH PASSION.
Jason:
REALLY FEELS LIKE
SHE -- SHE REALLY WANTS
TO GROW THE COMPANY.
YEAH, YOU CAN TELL THAT
SHE WANTS TO PARTNER WITH US.